the field kitchen next to a wood and the
cooks are preparing lunch for soldiers
training for battle
it's an unheralded job but it is
incredibly important soldiers can't
fight if they're hungry
petrochenko is in charge he's cooking a
meal for 30.
we've been searching for Sergey for
months because a year ago as the war
started he became an international
sensation after we interviewed him
we only knew him then as the boy on the
bridge
21 and scared he'd only ever fired 16
rounds and he was now guarding a bridge
on his own
he was frightened for his parents their
home was already surrounded by Russians
called to my parents they really scared
there's Russians in our village enemies
there's
tanks
heavy vehicle
ugh
I hope that they will be fine
sergey's story resonated with people
around the world over 50 million saw his
interview
ever since we've been inundated by
people wanting to know what became of
him
so he can't really believe the attention
hundreds of people in Social media's uh
text me every day every day they
asked me about how my family how how I'm
doing
the first days of the war in Keith were
surreal Air Raid Sirens blasted for the
first time
people took to shelters in the Metro
stations across the city
troops moved tanks and armored personnel
carriers beneath Bridges
I'm Sergey like many thought the Russian
Advance was inevitable every man was
scared at that time
every man think that now Russian can
invade the opposition and start shooting
at you and you can die eventually
he says he's grown up quickly over the
last 12 months like everyone here he
believes the Russians will be beaten
we will eventually push them back
to their borders maybe even forward
they will not win
in truth I never thought Sergey was cut
out for fighting and nor did he
but he's not scared anymore
he says he'll keep feeding his boys as
he calls him
the boy on the bridge is a man now
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine